[Applause]
welcome everyone welcome welcome
transfer students
[Applause]
welcome visiting international students
welcome Eli Whitney students welcome
first-year students
I'm so pleased so pleased to welcome you
all to Yale and to be with you now as we
have all come together before you start
out as Yale students classes start
tomorrow morning and when they do I
expect that you are going to get very
busy figuring out which ones you will
want to take the course election period
shopping period is going to give you a
chance to try out classes before you
sign up for them it's a very exciting
time and a big part of it is going to be
about juggling a lot of information as
you make up your minds before any of
that happens we have a chance this
afternoon
to think in the broadest sense about the
intellectual community that you are
joining and to start imagining your own
intellectual life here at Yale some of
you might know every class we want to
take some of you might just be the
opposite not knowing where to start or
maybe you're somewhere in between with a
vague idea of your next moves but an
openness to new ideas whatever you have
in mind I hope that this afternoon you
will get a sense of the world of ideas
that's waiting for you and so it's my
great pleasure to introduce our keynote
speaker
Emily Greenwood at Yale she is professor
of classics and chair of the classics
department she is one of Yale's most
distinguished faculty members and a
friend that I've long admired over the
years like many of you here today
professor Greenwood knows what it's like
to make real and metaphorical journeys
in pursuit of education she is half
British half Ugandan and was born in the
Cayman Islands when she was nine she
went away to boarding school a journey
of about five thousand miles and further
still in terms of crossing cultures
later she won a merit scholarship to an
International School in the South of
England then she went on to Cambridge
where she studied classics gaining her
BA ma MPhil and PhD degrees I believe
she had better grades than I did in
college after leaving Cambridge she
taught at the University of st. Andrews
in Scotland for six years before joining
Yale faculty in 2009 professor Greenwood
describes her career at Yale as a
continuation of that education her
academic work has focused on two main
areas the first is a study of ancient
Greek history a graffiti particular
focus on the authors through C through
CDs thank you I even spelled it out I
can't pronounce it and Herodotus I
didn't take I don't have a good
education CC duties and she is
interested in the emergence of history
as a discrete genre over 2,000 years
before the emergence of the modern
academic discipline of history and the
ways in which early Greek authors
writing in this genre expounded its
particular truth claims in competition
with other genres in short she is
interested in the question what does
history know that other genres and forms
of knowledge don't and how does it
establish this knowledge her other main
area of research explores how different
cultures societies and thinkers have
appropriated and reinvented Greek and
Roman classical antiquity from the late
19th century through the present for
example when do when do contemporary
politicians and military commanders
quote through cities and how is the
presence idea of Thucydides mediated by
complex traditions or to give another
example how have adaptations of Greek
tragedy been used to explore political
crises and powerful historical themes
such as apartheid civil war Colonials
colonialism genocide and the legacy of
Plantation slavery in different
countries including Nigeria South Africa
Northern Ireland and the United States
in all of these instances she is
interested in modes of friending the
past and analyzing the politics and
poetics of attempts to find common
ground with ancient Greece and Rome
whether this is done in pursuit of
liberation or oppression
she has published 20 book chapters and
articles exploring different aspects of
this classic relay and in 2011 she was a
joint winner of the 2011 Runciman Prize
a major British prize awarded each year
for scholarship on any aspect of ancient
or Byzantine Greece her current research
project is an experimental academic
prose work entitled an encyclopedia of
black classics when she isn't at Yale as
I mentioned that she has professor
classic center of the classics
department and last year she served as
chair of the FAS Faculty Senate which is
the representative body of faculty in
the Faculty of Arts and Sciences and she
continues to serve on the Senate's
Executive Committee she also has a
secondary appointment in the Department
of African American Studies when she
isn't teaching pursuing research or
involved in faculty governance professor
Greenwood says that she dreams of owning
a donkey enjoys rambling walks thinks
that birdsong is enough loves inventing
recipes around the spice cardamom gets
deliriously happy when she hears big
brass bands and Scottish pipe bands and
would love it if everyone would wear the
color yellow more the brighter the
better as you think about the journey so
you have all made just made and coming
here to you and the ones you are about
to start you cannot have a better guide
than Professor Greenwood who will speak
on the University we built please join
me in welcoming her
hello everyone good afternoon can you
all hear me
you are really quite a sight I wish you
could see the view that I see up here
all of you in your great array with the
domed ceiling it's very impressive and
not a little intimidating I dearly I
would have liked to practice what I
preach and to have worn yellow for this
occasion but we just moved house on
Friday and I spent a frantic 30 minutes
last night
randomly unpacking boxes but I didn't
find the box with the yellow clothes so
Yael blue for today which is no bad
thing we're going to go to lots of
different places in this talk so bear
with me but there's a lot that I want to
say to you by now I think you're experts
already in your brief time at Yale in
the genre of freshmen addresses so
please and this goes for all of the
talks that you'll hear at Yale listen
carefully but also listen critically
welcome to Yale welcome to our community
think of the traditional words of
welcome in every language you know
multiple but multiply that by the number
of leaves in Connecticut and for those
of you who are not so familiar with the
state believe me that's a very large
number of leaves and then double that
number and you'll begin then to approach
something of the measure of the Welcome
that I want to extend and convey to you
today I'm here to welcome you on behalf
of all of the faculty in FAS and to tell
you FAS stands with the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences and to tell you how much
we're looking forward to working with
you during your time at Yale who am I to
give you advice to take up your time in
this busy week where the problem
manifestly isn't a lack of information
but rather too much information I'm no
one and on everyone and everyone just as
each of you are I speak as an individual
I can't speak for the faculty in truth
you'd encounter as many different ideas
and ways of expressing them as there are
faculty here
and in the Faculty of Arts and Sciences
there are over a thousand of us so
there's a huge diversity of thought and
opinion but in thinking about what I
wanted to say to you today I've tried to
craft words which I think my colleagues
would have sent to him in some ways what
I'm going to say might seem like an odd
message even a Darwin but I hope that
its usefulness will slowly reveal itself
to you gradually if not immediately I
think you've already had more than
enough advice about how to navigate the
freshman experience and I know that you
will be fine in this because there's a
team of amazing people in all of your
residential colleges and in the Yale
College esteemed dean's office who will
continue to go out of their way to
support you and you're about to
encounter some of you've encountered
already at the academic fair but you'll
encounter for real and classes tomorrow
so many faculty who was going to demand
the best work from you and give you the
intellectual tools the encouragement and
the benign provocation that you're going
to need to produce this work so instead
my focus today is going to be on the
university writ large and your part in
it I'm not going to tell you how great
Yale is because you've already made up
your mind about this and also because
what makes Yale or any other university
great is the degree to which it fulfills
the role of a university the one bit
though of local prides but I'm going to
indulge in is the paradox of what I'll
call Yale call and thus Yale call in its
own way is instrumental to the rationale
of the university you're an example of
this phenomenon a diverse exceptionally
talented group of scholars I'm not
attempting to get into your good graces
by saying that I'm just acknowledging
the sheer dedication study and
intelligence which has gone into getting
you here today in ancient Greek and
Roman rhetorical theory there's a figure
of speech referred to in Latin as cap
Tati Oban
see I translated roughly a soliciting
goodwill from one's audience through
means of flattery I wouldn't try such a
transparent rhetorical commonplace on
such a clever audience because you'd see
right through it although you'll notice
that that disavowal of flattery in tells
another form of flattery and soon we
enter into a circular regression which
shares analogies with post modernists
and deconstructionist
techniques and critiques of the
operation of fiction this is just one of
the many paradoxes and problems that
you're going to be mulling over in
infinite varieties during your time at
Yale so maybe having deconstructed my
own disavowal of the rhetorical
commonplace I am going to gratify you
just this one little bit we are kind to
praise that's a paradoxical kind of
praise as a class you embodied the
paradox of Yale cool the coolness of
being to school for cool the coolness
which frees you up to exalt in the
fullest opportunities and possibilities
of the life of the mind unhampered by
the absurd pretense that you're not here
for a higher education and in this
unselfconscious intellectual focus is a
kind of deep preacher core or meta core
as I walk around campus I never tire of
overhearing campus conversations of
threads started in classes being taken
to exploratory and novel ends sometimes
these conversations are about robotics
about art about queer theory about music
about indigenous languages about history
about racial formations about religions
and about the infinite curiosity of what
there is to know and learn and the slow
and patient business or sometimes the
light bulb flash of out imagining what
has been thought before this is the
wander that has brought you here and
it's the wander that awaits you I don't
think that any of you I hope we'll have
the predicament that I had as a
first-year undergraduate at university
when I started I answered honestly
when my classmates asked me what I
wanted to be or to do what I wanted to
do with my education and I replied very
sincerely and naively that I wanted to
be a nun in a Greek Orthodox monastery
and that in addition to majoring in
classics I needed to learn enough modern
Greek to persuade the a Vitesse of a
monastery to admit me I guess I was
maybe banking a little bit on monastic
vows of silence to cover over my
linguistic ineptitude after that bit of
divulging and revelation my social life
was pretty circumscribed in my first
year at university yeah I was surprised
at first every time why when I left my
room and went into the communal kitchen
or sat down dining tables did my
presence have the suddenly chastening
effect and why was everybody suddenly on
their best behavior my saving grace was
that I was a varsity athlete which gave
some approximation to some kind of idea
of normal but the sporting question I
think before this audience is somewhat
of an oddball sport it was netball given
that we're an international crowd here
from 60 different countries do we have
any net ballers here today okay a few
welcome solidarity anyway I'm happy to
say obviously that the monastic vocation
did not work out very noble as it would
have been I examined my own motives I
diagnosed myself as a classic case of
spiritual opportunism I realized that it
was not a particularly honest act of
devotion to use my faith as a pretext
for getting lots of quiet study done I
was envisaging I guess monastic
libraries and thinking about the quiet
contemplation of Greek landscapes and
maybe a little bit of random archaeology
on the side in the monastery gardens so
I got over that thought long and hard
and Here I am today just to say if
you're harboring
outlandish schemes don't worry you will
or you won't but either way it will all
be okay I hope that from the faculty
that you've heard so far
you're reassured that the Guinness
Academic Asst is human too I asked
myself what did I think about my
professors as an undergraduate well when
I look back there wasn't much thinking
involved a moment's thought would have
told me that my conception of my
professors wasn't rational
instead awestruck I regarded them as a
community of ambulant Minds who had
Olympian powers of cogitation who like
whom as God's probably lived on nectar
ambrosia and shredded book leaves or
flambéed microchips if they even ate at
all
I definitely assumed that my problems
weren't their problems and that I
shouldn't talk about problems that I was
having as a minority student or
financial difficulties or questions of
faith or worries about family or more
existential questions of trying to work
out a sense of purpose for everything
maybe it was shyness maybe it was a
British thing but in retrospect I
realize I did my professors a disservice
in not talking to them in the round and
I missed out on so much wisdom an
immense diversity of experience so I
hope that you will talk to us all as
Dean Chan advised you to do in his talk
on Saturday it's easy to talk to faculty
with whom you have obvious experiences
in common and you absolutely should but
you should also be alert to unlikely
sources of support without exception all
of the professor's you're going to
encounter have experience that can help
you including experience borne of
struggles that you will not necessarily
Intuit on first meeting we all take your
welfare very seriously and we want you
to flourish here and to have the optimal
conditions in which you can concentrate
on your studies and Excel I hope in a
way that talking about the university as
I'm going to you an institution and a
concept that's bigger than all of us
that it will be a calming experience
in what is both an exciting anxious and
deeply inche introspective time so what
is this collective project on which
we're all embarked the University in the
term Yale University you'll already have
been inducted into many Yale traditions
and the Yale idiolect and we're going to
share in another tradition at the end of
this talk within a semester all of this
will be deeply familiar and next year
you'll be inducting others intern for
those of you who are in the new
residential colleges in Pauli Murray
college and in benjamin franklin college
you're going to experience this in a
particularly radical way as you take a
direct role in inventing the traditions
and building the sense of community
that's going to come and ident come to
ident come to characterize and define
the identity of those colleges and the
sense of place in them so while you
absolutely should enjoy all of these
traditions don't mistake them for what
this is all about Yale is not a
mausoleum and it's not pickled in
anyone's memory it's a dynamic living
educational institution and a global
community spanning many generations past
and hopefully many many many future
generations to come and the experience
of these generations of Yale and the
world around them will differ of course
markedly from ours just as our
experience difference markedly from that
of Yale known by past generations it's a
university that strives towards the
perfection of its educational and
intellectual mission and as such it is
located in the stream of change it seeks
to build on and benefit on the work for
those who've gone before as well as to
learn learn the cumulative lessons of
history sometimes this involves
searching for better insights than the
past sometimes this involves the
humility of learning insights that have
been forgotten we hope that you'll take
advantage of the many opportunities to
learn about yells hiss
and to be inspired by the past not
tyrannize by it
don't be over awed by Yale a good
university is not one that needs to
trade on an inflated image of itself
you've been admitted to Yale on merit
and the purpose of my talk today is to
co-opt you into our collective work in
this University
don't waste precious time doubting your
intelligent enough or learn it enough to
be here you are and we crave your ideas
and the energy and the kind of creative
inventive visionary intellectual
community which you're going to create
as a class together sometimes this
university will need your critique as
well and this critique is a vital part
of the loyalty that we hope you will
come to feel to Yale the loyalty of
giving it this university the benefit of
your best ideas of taking the time to
think outside of yourselves and your
immediate preoccupations and to find
ways of trying to improve the experience
of Yale for everyone in the Yale
community a university that cannot hold
up a critical mirror to itself and Frank
talk frankly and think frankly about the
challenges it faces where it excels and
where it needs to improve does not
deserve the name of the university and I
think we've done some very good critical
self study here at Yale in recent years
for this work of critical engagement
Yale will pay you back in kind this will
take the form of the work and the
intellectual care of faculty and
undergraduate instructors and other
academic advisors who will unpick your
ideas and help you to stitch them back
together again faculty will pour over
your problem sets who will involve you
in their labs who will show you why a
model or a theorem or a design doesn't
quite work and how to improve on it your
time as I've said is very precious and
we want you to fulfill your intellectual
potential to your utmost when I look
back on my own experience as an
undergraduate I regret the
well-intentioned people who wasted my
time by not telling me when my ideas
weren't clear enough good enough or
original enough
and I have a fond nostalgia not that I
felt it at the time for those who bought
me up short who were impatient and who
said that's not good enough
think harder study more rethink rewrite
and edit befriend the critics who are
not convinced by your ideas and those
who'll tell you why and help you find a
way to a better argument by the same
token avoid those who want their ideas
reflected back at them this might sound
like somewhat pedestrian advice and to
some extent it echoes some of the things
that you've heard already there's a
larger more urgent point here we make an
unmake we build and we really build this
community of ours through words we build
the imagined community of Yale
University through words and on a daily
basis our experience of the university
is mediated through language I thought
as I was thinking about what I wanted to
say to you today of a phrase that the
Irish poet Seamus Heaney sadly no longer
with us
used for a collection of essays the
government of the tongue it's a nice
ambiguous phrase that suggests both
governments through language distributed
across different media and the necessity
that those in power have to govern their
tongues and to speak in measured ways
there are lots of words flying around in
our national discourse at the moment and
if you like somewhat of a crisis with
this idea and concept of the government
of the tongue we hear words like ARBs
and we read them uses of words that we
thought we had put to bed or which we
hoped we had put to bed yesterday I was
reading the after words which the
novelist Toni Morrison wrote for the
second edition of her novel The Bluest I
first published in 1917 Toni Morrison
wrote the afterword in 1993 and
reflected about the urgency of her
writing that novel all those years ago
the urgency she felt to give voice to
the trauma of african-american history
which is sad though it needs repeating
at this time part inalienable part of an
indivisible American history she thought
about the urgency of how to give voice
to topics and matters and experiences
that had been kept quiet and the
challenge of finding a language and a
fictional craft adequate to express this
historical experience without falsifying
it looking back on this process in 1993
Morrison reflected that the same
assaults of language that she had felt
in line to the 1970s still pertained
then and she spoke of her amazement at
the currency the present 'less of her
artistic struggle with expressive
language in Morrison's words the
struggle of continuing to hear civilized
in quotation marks civilized languages
debase humans and the struggle of seeing
oneself preserved in the amber of
disqualifying metaphors
these were Morrison's words written in
her unerring idiom but Morrison could
have been echoing the Greek historian
Thucydides who was you've heard from
Dean Chang is one of the authors who
might work on some of you have heard I'm
sure in the media Graham Allison's
phrase the Thucydides trap as he uses it
it refers to the acidities as premise
that the underlying cause of the war
about which he wrote the war between the
Athenians and the Peloponnesians in the
last three decades of the fifth century
BCE that his underlying cause was the
fear which Athenian hegemony aroused in
the rival state of Sparta as Graham
Allison uses it the Thucydides trap
describes the threat that an expanding
power poses to an existing hegemon
leading to an escalation in hostilities
to the brink of war and sometimes
full-out warfare in the context of
interstate relations this is an
interesting and plausible idea although
there are many caveats including the
crew
roll into Citadis analysis that
intelligence and recent estimations of
power play in intervening in this
process but in truth the real Thucydides
trap is a much more basic insight and
it's an insight that is woven through
through Citadis as history this is an
insight about the precariousness of
human intelligence which in Thucydides
is analysis encompasses both the
uncertainty of decision-making
particularly in times of political
uncertainty and unrest as well as the
quality of information available to
those who lead and those who deliberate
and vote and it also refers to the
susceptibility of human thought human
thought and opinions to events and
changes in fortune one sphere in which
the acidities is analyzes the
precariousness of human intelligence to
give an example is in ethnic identities
under the pressure of unrest and on the
pressure of war his analysis of the
interstate hostilities between the
Athenians and the Peloponnesians and
other Greek States devotes a lot of time
to analyzing how political leaders
subtly Rhee conceived of cultural
differences and reinvented them as
inherent national differences along
ethnic and racial lines so I'm going to
quote a short passage from book three of
these two diseases history using a
translation by a scholar called Jeremy
Minot civil strife status and Greek
inflicted many a terrible blow on the
cities as always does and always will
happen while human nature remains what
it is though the degree and kind of the
damage may vary in each case according
to the particular circumstances in times
of peace and prosperity cities and
individuals alike show better judgments
because they do not fall prey to forces
beyond their control but war is a
violent teacher facilities uses this
arresting phrase the IOC das Carlos a
violent schoolmaster it robs us of the
means of easily providing for our daily
life and need
and it usually generates passions to
match our circumstances in this conflict
men assumed the right to reverse the
usual values in the application of words
to actions reckless audacity came to be
thought of as comradely courage while
farsighted hesitation became well
disguised cowardice
moderation was a form of unmanned
leanness and to understand everything
was to accomplish nothing wild
aggression was a mark of manhood while
careful planning for one's future
security was a glib excuse for evasion
the troublemaker was always to be
trusted the one who opposed him was to
be suspected the man who devised a
successful plot was intelligent the one
who detected it still cleverer but the
man who thought ahead to try and find
some different option was a threat to
party loyalty and must have been
intimidated by his opponents in short in
this period the way to be praised was to
be the first in planning an outrage and
the cheerleader for others who had
considered it the passage I've just
quoted is taken from Thucydides extended
description an analysis of the outbreak
of internal war on the island of course
IRA modern Corfu facilities describes
the violent breakdown of the political
community into sectarian camps and this
is basically what the Greek noun stathis
describes it's often translated into
English the civil war but I prefer the
translation popularized by the historian
jonathan pryce internal war prior to the
bit i've quoted facilities described the
manifestation and effects of status as
it was on kathira and then he pans out
in the bit I've just read to analyze the
common factors and patterns of internal
war when they break out in political
communities throughout history from his
perspective in the 5th century BCE
beyond that context I don't think I need
to gloss these words
that's not to say that the acidities is
meaning is not complex the
interpretation of the Greek certainly is
and you can appreciate I'm sure how
different interpretive communities might
find it hard to reach a neutral
agreement about what cube what
intelligences and how to define good and
bad intelligence or whether or not
aggression has any place in politics
this is precisely Thucydides point and
the real underlying Thucydides trap
which he exposes again and again in his
history is the necessity for
intellectual analysis of historical
events that takes ideology into account
but is able as far as possible to rise
above it and the trap in question is
when that intellectual cognition and
reflection and cross-examination and
deep study of history is absent
to quote my Yale colleague professor
David blight those who want to make
history need to know some history in
recent weeks and months we've seen many
examples of the changing fortunes of
words as usage and meanings becomes
contested and words get weaponized
patriotism American great liberal
intellectual and sometimes words that a
painful source of history are picked and
made to bleed again hateful words that
are not a code for anything words that
speak all too plainly as the university
community in common with other
universities in the USA in the rest of
the world we've been on the receiving
end of many formulaic put downs in the
last year and a half
last year Yale students were often
derided as snowflakes or a coddled
community more seriously although that
was offensive colleagues who work on
climate science on race on Islam and
other sensitive topics and who had
engaged in public comment using their
expertise as researchers have been the
recipients of hateful emails phone calls
and threats meanwhile hostile critics
piled in to excoriate the idea of a Yale
bubble so
oddly engulfed in political correctness
when what they were denouncing was the
commitment at the heart of Yale's
curriculum and the research of its
faculty to questioning parochialism and
bubble minded generalizations
paradoxically in the name of
constitutional freedoms of speech these
voices tried and are still trying to
regulate what students and faculty at
universities should and shouldn't think
should and shouldn't say and as we've
seen at some universities the kinds of
courses that faculty should and should
not teach intimidation in the name of
freedom of speech is a flat-out fallacy
universities like ours that exists to
facilitate and promote free and robust
inquiry do not never will bend to these
pressures and this unchanging on
negotiable commitment to inquiry
however inconvenient the findings of
research might be for different
audiences is unshaken I'm not here
claiming that universities have a
monopoly on knowledge production and the
preservation of knowledge they don't and
I fully understand the impatience and
the resentment from members of different
publics when universities presume to
speak for everyone we don't have that
prerogative but universities have a
contract with these different publics
a singular responsibility towards the
cultivation of inquiry knowledge and
research and to do this work for the
communities societies in world in which
they exist this also entails a constant
and sincere effort to seek out ways in
which universities can serve local
national and global communities better
through listening through learning
through studying and engaging in
partnerships expertise is not a badge of
status it's just a basic requirement of
the work that is done in universities
and it's the rationale for their
existence and for our existence no more
and no less and when I put it like that
it's clear that our membership of Yale
our decision to freely associate
ourselves with Yale carries a charge
that is much bigger than
all of us in an essay published in 1918
the jamaican-born cultural theorist
Stuart Hall referred to the influence of
master paradigms by which he meant
trammeled closed intellectual systems in
his web of disciplines cultural studies
as an I quote the prison house of
thought there's a half echo here I think
in Stuart Hall's choice of language to
the title of George lambing the
Barbadian novelist George lamins first
novel in the castle of my skin which was
published in 1953 lambing had chosen a
line from one of derek Walcott's early
collections of poetry entitled epitaph
for the young twelve Cantor's published
in 1949 in one of those Cantor's the
poet narrator muses on a quasi Autobot
autobiographical scenario of young
interracial adolescent love sorted by
divisions of race and class and the
Cantor contains the lines you in the
castle of your skin.i
the swineherd at this time and in this
historical moment I want to exhort you
in your work to devote deep thought to
the related dangers of the prison house
of thought and the castle of one skin as
Lama used that phrase in choosing it for
the title of his novel he was referring
in the first instance to the tragic
internalization of exterior racialized
projections on citizens of colonial
societies in his case colonial Barbados
and the transformative dehumanizing
effect that systems of race and the
legacy of Plantation slavery had on the
coming into being of an adolescent
consciousness but he also meant it
outwards as a critique on exteriorized
racial pretty projections which split up
and divided our communities into castles
of skin color you're going to be
challenged in all kinds of ways
mediating the
wean these different concepts one that
hits you immediately as you read Yale
college's academic regulations is the
juxtaposition of these two passages
you'll read if you haven't already Yale
College is an academic community
dedicated to the advancement of learning
students freely associate themselves
with the college and in doing so affirm
their commitment to ala philosophy of
mutual tolerance and respect all
students admitted to Yale should
understand the responsibility this
places on them if any member of the
community should interfere with its
functions or show himself or herself
show themself unable or unwilling to
assist in them the community may find it
necessary to protects itself by
suspending or terminating his or her
membership or their membership indeed by
formal vote of the Yale College faculty
is affirmed its commitment to protect
free expression and peaceful dissent and
to preserve mutual respect and
charitable relations among all members
of the Yale community sometimes these
ideals a philosophy of mutual tolerance
and respect and the commitment to
protect free expression are indirect
attention attention to each other and
these tensions do not cancel each other
out to pretend otherwise would be to
insult your intelligence and to simplify
a series of complex and multifaceted
debates to find the balance in upholding
freedom of speech and upholding a
philosophy of mutual tolerance and
respect and upholding at the same time
the university's collective commitment
to protect free expression requires and
will require review great wisdom
discernment and forbearance sometimes as
we've seen the banner of free speech is
hijacked for nefarious purposes
sometimes it's used as cover for the
promulgation of pseudo intellectual
bigotries if this happens and I hope it
doesn't happen here on campus but if it
does know it for what it is and know
that the University's commitment to
protect free expression does not equate
to coercion
listen to words that wound and hurt some
of you in your experience already
veterans of these words and some of you
have observed to use a phrase the poet
Derek Walcott the pain of history that
words contain in the experience and
lives of your family members and members
of your communities so don't allow
yourselves to be patronized by the
fallacious argument that exposure to all
arguments is inherently good for you and
educational previous generations have
lived through these lies so that you
don't have to by all means
and absolutely grant others the right to
speak and others the right to listen to
what they want to but you don't have to
ever listen to words sown in prejudice
and hate I repeat you don't have to
there are arguments and words that
intend to wound and divide that come
from no kind place and that once unheard
cannot be unheard and I have no patience
with anyone who tries to tell me that
this is just the free play of ideas the
whole tired reprehensible business of
misanthropy of hating one's fellow human
beings of looking down on those who are
different from oneself is outmoded and
is bankrupt and it's not part of the
work of our intellectual community it's
profoundly unoriginal and not welcomed
here you'll find many different views of
course challenging educational
provocative views about freedom of
speech among Yale faculty but we speak I
think with one voice unequivocally in
giving you this reassurance so look out
for each other in your time here and in
your intellectual work and respect each
other
profoundly each and every one of you and
all of you collectively will enrich this
University with your experience your
talents and your commitments and I
repeat that each and every single one of
you and all of you collectively and
there are no hierarchies in this
plurality of experience whether you come
from this town or the next town from
this state or any of the other 49 states
of the united states or from the other
59 countries represented here today
whether you're joining us from high
school or as an Eli Whitney scholar or a
veteran or a member of the Army or
marine or air force corpse students who
have transferred to Yale from other
universities all of you and each of
every one of you I'd ask you in the
weeks ahead as you continue to settle in
to Yale
to envisage a mental picture and to
cultivate it of another student and
their journey to Yale their communities
their families their experience and
their hopes and fears and please take
very seriously your responsibility as
part of the community that is receiving
them as this will be done to you in turn
when you are talking ask yourself who is
not and when you're talking who are you
not listening to can you talk like
listening in your work can you write
like listening can you emulate the self
description of the Belarusian writer
spell on Alekseyevich winner of the
Nobel Prize in Literature in 2015 who
offered a striking description of
herself in her Nobel lecture as a human
ear listen greedily and critically
including to this talk find the
potential and promise in your
interlocutors arguments as well as the
fault lines and contradictions can you
capture many voices and what you say and
in what you write this is part of the
polyphony and the poly mafia a greek
phrase meaning plurality of learning
which President Sall avait extolled in
his speech to you on Saturday okay so to
draw things to a conclusion on the
subject of poly mafia much knowledge
knowing many things you already have
learned that Yale will offer you many
opportunities for educational
inspiration and education many more than
you can realistically take advantage of
try not to be a lover of sights and
sounds for their own sakes and to chase
the easy quick fix of intellectual
gratification instead seek out in your
courses difficulty
embrace it of the vast array of courses
on offer and of the events over and
above the regular course offerings in
Yale College I'd like to call your
attention to three in the immediate
future and you'll be hearing about many
more the first event I want to call your
attention to you is an academic
conference on racism anti-semitism and
the radical right which we held on
September the 10th and 11th in the
Whitney humanities Center this is an
opportunity to hear national and
international academics address the
history of racism of anti-semitism of
fascism of white supremacy and other
radical white wing political movements
the second event I want to draw your
attention to you is the Wyndham Campbell
literary festival which ran strips and
timber the 13th to the 15th here you'll
have the opportunity to hear from the
recipients of the 2017 Donald wind and
sand M Campbell literary prizes come and
hear their craft and be inspired by the
example of their lives and writing and
their journeys and adventures at the
frontiers of human imagination and also
check out whether or not you're
interested in majoring in astronomy
check out the lightener observatory and
the planetarium which is open on tuesday
nights to enable you to scan the skies
to look at stars and to look at them
below so to conclude our collective work
as part of this university is serious
business and I know and we know that
you're ready for it
make us proud please class of 21 and
make yourselves proud thank you for
listening
thank you thank you so much professor
Greenwood for those moving words and
address and thank you all for just being
so great for for engaging with Yale so
positively over the past few days we're
so excited to have you here we're eager
to have you in our classes starting
tomorrow you know after this event your
colleges are going to formally welcome
you with a with a very nice dinner and
program and and before that before we
leave this hall today we're going to
introduce you to another very important
tradition our our song bright college
years you have the lyrics in hand we
have the the amazing yell glee club here
to share teach you the song together
with director Jeffrey Dalma and
professor Thomas Murray at the Oregon
the way this was going to work is that
the glee club is going to sing the first
verse and you can just listen and then
after that you will sing the first and
second verse together with the glee club
and at the end we're at the last line
for God for country for Yale you'll
you'll do this just follow what they do
okay so so yeah so thank you so much and
have a great year
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]